What is a freelancer and how can
they help you build your startup?
Freelancers are workers who charge
an hourly or project based rate for
their skills without being considered
an employee of your company.
There's people with all types of skills
that offer their services as freelancers
and there's a few basic ideas you should
understand before working with one.
First let's look at some of the benefits
of working with a freelancer.
Freelancers can be great for
your business.
If you don't want to commit to a full
time employee or have a limited and
temporary need.
For example, maybe you need to use
specialized experience with a technology
you don't know or
need to complete a series of small tasks
that would take too long to do yourself.
If you have any of
these requirements for
your business this could be an excellent
opportunity to work with a freelancer.
While there are benefits to
working with the freelancer.,
it's important to understand
some of the downsides.
First, working with
freelancers can be very tricky.
It's difficult to evaluate
the skills of a freelancer and
because of this it's also risky.
If you don't have recommendations
from people you personally know
then you need to evaluate the skills of
each freelancer from their portfolio.
Also communication can be a problem.
You'll need to be aware of language
barriers and time zone differences and
be patient with some of
the issues this can cause.
While it can be difficult to find
a freelancer there are some great
platforms available for
you to make your decisions.
To start try using websites
such as Freelancer, Fiverr, and
UpWork but
there are many other possibilities.
The benefits of using these sites is
that they usually have some type of
quality assurance in place for
their workers.
There's also often more than one person
on the team to help minimize the risk
that your project won't be completed.
And most of your communication
will be done through writing so
be careful that you're clear and
concise about what you need from
any freelancer you're working with.
Freelancers provide an amazing
opportunity to get the skills you need
for your business.
Once you get used to the process,
it can really help accelerate
your growth as a company.
Take some time to decide if you think
it's possible to use freelancers to get
any of the skills you need for
your business.